(upbeat rock music)
- I think I had the most
style when I was a little kid,
and my mom was dressing
me, because I was so cute.
Everything was, like,
nineties and colorful
and that is, like, back in now.
- I wouldn't really say I had style
when I was in lower grade school.
I don't really think in
kindergarten or first grade
I really knew what I was wearing,
I think that mostly my
mom picked out my clothes
and it had a lot of cartoon characters
and little, cute, matching
skirts and dresses,
type of style, is what I wore.
- Right when I started
transitioning into my preteen years,
that's when things kinda
got a little rough.
In the picture, at that age, I
(sighs)
I don't think it was very stylish.
I had these pair of boots
and they were my lucky boots,
I would wear them everywhere I went.
I would wear them with every outfit,
even though it didn't match.
But I felt like my most true
self in them, at the time.
- I could remember my mom
taking me to Limited Too
for my first-day-of-school outfit
and me being so excited to pick it out
and the cute, little flowy
skirt with the matching top.
It was just like, being in that store
was such a great feeling
and it meant school was about to start.
(jaunty music)
- I'm trying to find
this outfit that I wore on
the first day of kindergarten.
- This is what I looked like.
- I think we should probably
try to find the jumper.
- As you can see, I had the camo shirt
with the white long-sleeve underneath, but
they were connected.
- Let's go try to find it.
This might work. That might work.
If it's button-up.
I think that one could work.
- I think this one would
be a good undershirt
to go under my camo shirt.
- I think this could work.
I think that's probably as
close as you're gonna get.
- I think we found it.
This is the one.
Although this one doesn't
have turtles on it,
which I'm really upset about.
- I'm wearing a pink
backpack in my picture.
This actually, probably, is perfect.
- I had these pair of boots.
I wore them all the time!
This is what my boots looked like.
(jaunty piano music)
(rap music)
- [Nichole] Hey, guys, what
do you think of my outfit?
Do you like my hair?
- Umm...
- [Nichole] They're laughing at me!
I don't think they like my outfit.
- [Regina] Oh my God.
(laughing)
I look like a man.
No.
- Hey, Eric.
- You could be on,
like, Dora the Explorer.
- God, that's the best
compliment I've gotten all day!
Swiper, no swiping!
- Oh man!
- Some people didn't notice any difference
in what I was wearing, which
is actually kinda funny.
- So basically, everyone hated the boots.
It looked really cute back then.
I don't know if it looks cute now.
- There's this little girl on
her actual first day of school
and she looked up at me
and then looked at her mom,
and then looked back at me, like,
"What is this girl wearing?"
She had a really cool backpack, though,
I was kinda jealous, to be honest.
- If I had to go back and change
anything about my wardrobe,
I don't think I would.
Even though it was not a good look,
that's who I was.
I was awkward and weird and
I didn't know how to smile,
but that's who I was, so I
wouldn't change anything.
(upbeat music)